I can't be happy when I don't have a
partner so we grew up in a culture
that's very couple oriented and so
people who don't find partners or don't
find partners for a long time feel
deviant they feel discriminated against
they're not invited to parties and so it
could cause a lot of unhappiness I
talked about the research that's
actually been written a lot by béla
DiPaolo who's a researcher in this area
about you know how happy a lot of single
people are so so it turns out that there
are many lifelong singles in fact I
believe half of the adults in the United
States today are single there are many
lifelong singles especially women who
are very happy who are no less happy
than married or you know partnered
people they have they tend to have a lot
of friends a dozen or more really deep
friendships I mean can those of you who
are married and have children you know
can you say the same for yourself do you
have a dozen really deep French of the
with whom you you know keep in touch
with on a very regular basis single
people tend to be very close to their
family members you know nieces nephews
you know siblings parents and their
friends are their own you know when you
think about it when you're married and
with and with children a lot of your
friends are not really chosen by you
they might be your partner's friends or
they might be your kids friends parents
but when you're single you tend to
choose your friends the bottom line is I
mean what I like to highlight is that
there are a lot of single people who are
very happy and so if you have not found
a partner or who if you're not sure if
you want to compromise or you you want
to live with someone else for the rest
of your life there's just a lot of hope
for you out there from from the science
so if you're single maybe you're not so
happy being single instead of kind of
focusing so desperately on finding a
partner I talked about you know becoming
your best possible single self and
there's there's research on what are
called best possible selves and they're
basically kind of ideal visions of
ourselves sort of what when you think
about yourself in five years in ten
years and 20 years you know who do you
want to be what kind of person do you
want to be what do you want to be doing
so basically what research suggests is
that focusing on that focusing on the
future focusing on your goals makes
people happy you know striving actually
makes people much happier than actually
then even achieving and then maybe in
the process you might find you might
find someone but but you're not you know
you're gonna be hopefully you're gonna
be happy sort of pursuing all the
different myriad goals in your life and
becoming the best person you can be
that's a much healthier approach than
just sit around and you know mope about
the fact that you're single and so again
this really ties back to the - one of
the themes of the book that happiness
lies within that you could be a single
person and you could be a very happy
single person and it a lot of it depends
on sort of what you focus on what do you
think about or you can be single person
and you can dwell on the fact that
you're single and how depressed that
makes you and be an unhappy person so so
again happiness really lies within us
not outside of us